what are we going to do about people who
exercise power outside of the the limits
and and their right to do so very little
usually and it's why we've got to take a
much tougher line with them you saw
desantis do this with dr fauci who's the
most egregious example of some
technocrat taking more power than he
deserves and desantis is really
ratcheting up the rhetoric as dr fauci
is trying to avoid a congressional
investigation by republicans if
republicans retake the house and or the
senate as fouchy is saying oh cam listen
i'm going to speed up my retirement
table here please forget about forget my
name i'll be over there i'm saying
helena you've got ron desantis
ratcheting up the attacks speaking as
bluntly as i've ever heard him speak and
i'm just sick of seeing him i know he
says he's going to retire someone needs
to grab that little elf and chuck him
across the potomac this i really love
this line from desantis it's the right
kind of rhetoric it's extremely funny
it's true it is in a word trumpian